okay let's dig into these new DNC debate
requirements the Democratic Party has
put in place some new and stricter
requirements to make the third and
fourth officially DNC sanctioned primary
debates which are scheduled to take
place in will put it up on the screen in
a second but I believe it's September
and October is when debates 3 & 4 will
take place and there's a lot to talk
about here and I want to sort of do this
justice and really go through it piece
by piece and think it through because a
lot of the reactions I've seen online to
these requirements are not making a lot
of sense
so first let's zoom out a little bit why
do we have requirements why do we have
minimum standards that need to be met to
participate in debates well if you have
no standards at all you can end up with
dozens 50 I mean you've got to have some
you know does anyone who announces a
candidacy get to participate in DNC
sanctioned debates does anybody who's on
the ballot in even one state get to
participate it's chaos if you have no
minimum requirements whatsoever but on
the other side of this we know 2016
being a prime example that the DNC has
ways of influencing the Democratic
primary that can be anti progressive
anti insurgent candidate and basically
Pro status quo Pro establishment
candidate and so what we don't want to
have are requirements that are so strict
that they preempted the possibility of
having serious insurgent progressive
candidates and challengers for the 2020
Democratic primaries so the first
debates are in late June and late July
we're very close I mean we're a month
from the first debate and the
requirements for those first two debates
which are going to be split into a and B
because the field is still so large the
requirement for those first two debates
which will be debate 1a and 1b and
debate 2a and 2b we've known about these
for a while
65,000 individual donors and you need to
be polling 1% in three qualified polls
closer to the date of the debate so the
Pope will look at the polls now if they
who would be in as of today but what's
going to matter is how the candidates
are doing closer to the debates in mid
to late June
so we'll put up on the screen for you
also the requirements for the following
debates so first two debates 65k donors
and 1% in three qualified polls the DNC
has now added stricter requirements for
debates 3 & 4 & in debates 3 & 4 the
requirements double the donor number to
a hundred and thirty thousand donors and
they also double the polling requirement
to two percent instead of one percent
and that needs to be in four rather than
just three polls
so the criticisms immediately from some
people have been this is going to
destroy the field this is unfair to
smaller candidates this is a pro
establishment DNC move this is
potentially going to alienate donors to
those lower ranked candidates because
they will say well why am I even gonna
bother if these new even higher
requirements are going to keep them out
of the third and fourth debate anyway we
want the field to stay bigger for a
longer period of time I think we have to
break this down into two parts the donor
requirement and the polling requirement
okay let's first talk about the 2%
polling requirement the DNC the
convention is in it's in the summer I
don't know if it's scheduled for June
July or August but it's in summer of
2020 if you don't have 2% by the third
debate in September I believe it is
completely reasonable to say you can't
continue being in the officially
sanctioned DNC debates if you can't get
to 2% after two national debates and six
or seven months of campaigning for most
of these candidates you don't have a
shot and you are becoming a distraction
period and you're taking time away from
the candidates who are in this thing
having time to better flesh out and talk
about their ideas I have no problem
whatsoever with a 2% polling requirement
for the third and fourth debates the
question mark for me is a hundred and
thirty thousand donors okay bill share
it out on Twitter that back in 2008 John
Edwards had like 20,000 donors or
something like that at a relatively
advanced point in the campaign he was a
serious candidate in terms of the
polling but he did not have a hundred
and thirty thousand donors so I think
that it's really important to point out
that if we want to make a case that
these requirements are too strict
it's got to be along the number of
donors line I don't think there is any
serious case to be made that 2% by
September is too high of a threshold now
let's understand a little bit about what
the effect would be of the 1% in two
percent polling requirements based on
today's numbers okay to be in the first
debates you need to pull one percent if
we look at the current average polling
remember what matters is how they pull
right before the debates not right now
but let's imagine that we had today's
polling as the sort of way to decide who
gets into the debates you have Bennett
Bullock Hickenlooper Seth Moulton Bill
DeBlasio Delaney kirsten gillibrand
marianne williamson Tim Ryan and Tulsi
Gabbard that's ten candidates none of
them are polling 1% right now okay there
are or rather I'm sorry there are 10
candidates who are polling 1% right now
and that's still a very solid number for
the first and second debate there is a
broad range of opinion represented among
those 10 candidates so there would be a
bunch of people who would be out today
if the requirement were 1% but we would
still have 10 people participating very
reasonable for this early in the game if
the 2 percent requirement were put in
place today you would still have Joe
Biden Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren
Kamala Harris Pete Buddha judge Beto
O'Rourke and Cory Booker that's 7
candidates ok if we have 7 candidates by
the third debate it is very reasonable
and again if you participate in two
national debates and you can't get 2
percent I don't believe
you deserve to keep taking up space on
the stage you don't have a shot so the
only debate for me is about the
individual donor number I get that
donations are a way to prove your
viability but a hundred and thirty
thousand donors at 14 months before the
election which is effectively what
September will be that might be too high
okay can somebody polling 1.8 percent in
October end up being the nominee by June
I don't think they can can someone with
only a hundred thousand donors in a cow
in October end up being the nominee in
June I think they can't I mean it may be
a long shot compared to some of the
other candidates but that's where the
focus should be on getting these
requirements changed 1% to be in debates
1 & 2 2% to be in debates 3 & 4
completely reasonable and I have not
seen any serious argument that that is
too high of a requirement if you think
I'm wrong let me know we will have a
poll on the David Pakman show
Instagram page about this at David
Pakman show check that out
follow the David Pakman show on
Instagram and while you're there follow
me on instagram @ David Pakman as well
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
David Pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25 thousand video
classes on just about anything you can
think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy to use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video